[музика]
вітаємо це У фокусі Європа яллара балола
Ласкаво просимо літо в розпалі Європа
переживає чергову посуху є побоювання що
наступний екологічна катастрофа не за
горами подібна до цієї що сталася на
річці Одер минулого літа мільйона
мертвих риб було знайдено в тій річці на
кордоні між Німеччиною та Польщею
то не ту ж дістали з води
висока температура і низький рівень води
спричинили масовий ріст та золотистих
водоростей токсичних для прісноводної
риби
Одер знову з'являється купа мертвої риби
виявлення причин цього триває особливо в
районах на південному заході Польщі
у членів виявили надзвичайно високий
рівень солі у притоках річки сіль Сприяє
росту токсичних золотистих водоростей
не лише екологи стурбовані загрозою
нової екологічної катастрофи
Ричард гаврон затятий любитель риболовлі
але він починає думати що часи коли він
ловив окуня щуку чи судака-водарі
закінчилися
Здається це відбувається знову риба
вимирає в річці Одер на кордоні між
Польщею та Німеччиною
ми бачимо її біля шлюзів така ж ситуація
спостерігається і у притоках на
польському боці нещодавно повідомлялося
про сотні кілограмів мертвої риби вбитої
золотистими водоростями
[музика]
ришарт гаврон виріс на одрі граючись на
його берегах
з дитинства він ходив туди на риболовлю
та ці дні минули
тут
я вчився рибалити тут я виріс
тепер це схоже на замах на мої спогади
влітку 2022 року близько 400 тонн риби
майже половина всіх рибних запасів воду
та його притоках вимерло
аналітики звинуватили у цьому високу
солоність річкової води але Звідки
взялася вся ця сіль вугільні шахти у
цьому регіоні головні підозрювані адже
вони скидають високосолоні стічні води у
річки грін-піс попросив професора хімії
лесика-паздерського провести
розслідування
коли він намагався взяти пробу води біля
однієї з шахт з'явилася поліція і
співробітники служби безпеки почалися
палки дискусії його дослідження було
явно небажаним
Хто ви взагалі така Ви не могли б
представитися
А так ви не хочете тоді знаєте що я
вважатиму що вас тут немає
професор паздерський і його команда
зосереджується на вугільній шахті
хеленба
Вони беруть зразки води склодниці
притоки озера
стічні води із заводу вже змішалися тут
із річковою водою
дружина поздерського допомагає і з
аналізом
тест показує вміст солі що в 6 разів
перевищує норму
звісно солі містяться у воді природним
чином але не в таких великій кількостях
натомі стічні води шахт містять
величезну кількість солей
Зараз ми виміряємо солоність стічних вод
шахти хелемба
професор паздерський знаходиться стічну
трубу шахти
Саме тут стічні води стікають у річку
день за днем майже безперервно
висока солоність створює ідеальні умови
для золотих водоростей
Зазвичай вони ростуть лише у морській
воді і для прісноводних риб і є
смертельними
активісти грінпіс виміряли тут біля
вугільних шахт надзвичайно високий
рівень солоності
[музика]
Як бачите це у 18 разів більше ніж у
чистій річковій воді
проблема підвищення солоності зростатими
з кожним роком оскільки рівень води в
річках значно нижчий
особливо влітку коли стоїть сильна спека
тому що вода випаровується а сіль - ні
коли ми зв'язалися з керівництвом шахти
воно заперечило будь-яку
відповідальність за загибель риби
наполягаючи на тому що дотримуються всіх
законодавчих вимог щодо утилізації
стічних вод польські підприємства
скидають відходи в Одер та його притоки
по більш ніж десяти тисяч труб
і роблять це цілком легально у Польщі
немає встановлених обмежень на вміст
солі у стічних водах ми цікавимося
планами польського Міністерства охорони
навколишнього середовища щодо зменшення
солоності води у річках
відповідь електронною поштою це загальна
інформація про контроль за забрудненням
води та запевнення що запобігання
подібним катастрофам у майбутньому це
абсолютний пріоритет але жодного слова
про сольове забруднення
реакція людей які живуть вздовж ору
неоднозначно у Вроцлаві дехто обурений
офіційною реакцією А дехто навіть не чув
про нещодавню загибель риби
тут є політичні причини
хтось не хоче називати винуватця Ось і
все
не можна сказати що риба водирі зараз
дорога
особисто ми не так часто контактуємо з
водою Ми не ходимо на риболовлю тому не
дуже цікавимося цим питанням із кожним
новим повідомленням про загибель риби
водурі Рішард гаврон який колись любив
рибалити тут все більше втрачає надію на
те що щось зміниться на краще
я втратив довіру до цієї річки
Я не вірю цій річці
Я не знаю як можна ловити рибу в цій
забрудненій воді
восени у Польщі відбудуться вибори і
можливо буде сформовано новий уряд це
Промінь Надії для багатьох тих хто живе
вздовж одягу і не бажає сидіти склавши
руки і спостерігати як гине риба
знайти доступне житло в Лондоні сьогодні
все одно що виграти у лотерею британська
столиця одне з найдорожчих міст світу
для оренди житла ринок настільки
конкурентний що людям часто доводиться
викидати купу грошей за маленький
приміщення
таке люди як Луїза хемфрі відчувають
житлову кризу на власному досвіді після
довгих пошуків вона нарешті знайшла
квартиру для оренди але душевний спокій
не проходить
оскільки нерви на межі
від дефіциту житла до дефіциту робочої
сили в Румунії де сотні тисяч людей
покинули країну із 2007 року коли
Румунія приєдналась до ЄС
курса вищих заробітних плат у Західній
Європі призвела до величезного дефіциту
робочої сили будівельна галузь лікарні
та готелі відчувають нестачу персоналу у
тому числі і в місті Констанца
Ніколай буковело власник готелю бачить
рішення у залученні трудових мігрантів з
Азії ця ідея підтримується урядом в
бухаресті але для багатьох тих хто
прибуває за кордону Румунія - Це просто
ворота до кращого життя у Європі
у вас проблеми з басейном
Ніколай букувала володіє кількома
готелями все має бути готова до
проїзду головний біль нестача
працівників
нічого не працюватиме без іноземних
робітників
Я сам не знаю як переконати румун який
працює наприклад у Франції повернутися
назад іноді хочеться просто все продати
Я щоранку себе запитую а що буде далі
Він живе в часи кризи яка почалася
багато років тому нестача робочої сили
відколи Румунія приєдналася до ЄС у 2007
році багато румунів емігрували до
Західної Європи
вони потрібні тут на чорноморському
узбережжі та за його межами згідно з
оцінками півмільйона румунських робочих
місць залишаються незаповненими причина
очевидна
він поки
які пропонує Румунія не привабливі для
цього покоління і тому вони їдуть за
кордон
ці люди тут щоб Заповнити цю діру
робітники з Азії Непалу Індії Пакистану
ті хто чекає тут перед бухареським і
міграційним офісом заплатили до шести
тисяч євро агенством із працевлаштування
у себе на батьківщині аби легально і
мігрувати до Румунії
У них є візи але проблеми з дозволом на
проживання карткою
Ti
Я стою в черзі вже два місяці але так і
не можу забрати своє посвідчення особи
що відбувається у мене візи лише на три
місяці вона закінчилася Мені потрібен
дозвіл на проживання
імміграційний офіс перевантажений через
Нову стратегію уряду цього року Румунія
хоче видати 100 тисяч дозволів на роботу
громадянам країн не членів ЄС у 17-му
році Румунія видали лише 5 з половиною
тисяч дозволів
на думку таких румунських роботодавців
як ніколи про це йде повільно на кухні
його готелю досі не вистачає працівників
ти готуєш рис ні картоплю з м'ясом
у даянга діснеяки і його колега Самір
обидва зі шрі-ланки вони ніколи раніше
не працювали кухарями
переважна більшість не працювали в цій
галузі агентство каже нам що вони вже
мають досвід але це нісенітниця
вони Ніде не працювали так що і
працювали то не на тій посаді яка нам
потрібна
румунські колеги навчають їх якомога
швидше
у де ж ніцелі готові і курячі крильця
сьогодні вони готують казка-вал пане сир
у паніровці класичний проста румунська
страва
відтоді як ми тут ми багато дізналися
про румунську кухню
Вони працюють тут теж з минулого року це
незвично і це велика вдача для
шеф-кухарки
Я рада що вони обидва залишилися в
Румунії На відміну від інших які просто
виїхали нам це трохи полегшило життя
вони вже адаптувалися і нам не потрібно
знову починати усе з нуля
багато хто намагається переїхати до
західної Європи без документів
використовуючи Румунію як транзитний
пункт пояснюють співробітники у даянга
каже що хоче залишитися він заробляє 500
євро на місяць
він ділить Цю кімнату в готелі зі своїм
колегою 26-річний хлопець сумує за
сім'єю але повертатися назад не варіант
дитині
Я люблю шрі-ланку але економіка там
погана Дуже важко виживати
іноді Я готував їжу і продавав її
сусідам Ось так ми жили там
за його словами Він вивчав туризм але
заробляв лише 50 євро на місяць час від
часу перебиваючись випадковими
заробітками він бачить Румунію як країну
можливостей
вони пропонують так багато роботи для
азіатів я бачу дуже багато людей які
працюють у доставці фастфуду ресторанах
і таких як ми які працюють у готелях тут
дуже багато вакансій
він не часто буває на пляжі у напруженні
літні місяці Він працює 7 днів на
тиждень а більшу частину зароблених
грошей відсилає додому батькам Одного
дня каже він у нього буде власний бізнес
можливо у Великій Британії
неподалік робітники з Індії будують цю
багатоповерхівку з розкішними квартирами
не на камеру ми дізналися що тут п'ятеро
людей живуть в одній кімнаті і не всі
хто будує майбутнє Румунії хочуть
залишатися тут надовго вище зарплати в
Західній Європі за ту саму роботу надто
спокусливі
вони можуть стати рятувальним колом для
тих хто опинився під завалами службові
собаки з їхнім гострим нюхом мають
вирішальне значення для рятувальних
робіт після землетрусів їх
використовували в Туреччині на початку
цього року коли землетрус там забрав
десятки тисяч життів експерти
попереджають що наступний землетрус лише
питання часу
це спонукало дресирувальника собак
юктана екера вдосконалити носи свої
чотирилапих друзів у своєму рідному
місті Стамбулі б'юк Там має великий
вибір
гляньчити їжу дрімати гратися чи просто
вештатися безпритульні собаки невід'ємна
частина міського пейзажу Стамбула
їхня кількість оцінюється у півмільйона
і продовжує зростати
багатьох Турків вони дратують але час
від часу собаки зустрічають привітні
обличчя наприклад гектана ерра
він дресирувальник собак і завжди
зупиняється на узбіччі щоб погладити їх
Я думаю що та чорна самка мала поганий
досвід контакту з людьми
але цей самець довірливий ймовірно у
нього була сім'я але його покинули
у якера є ідея для собак і для людей
Сьогодні він шукає особливих вуличних
собак із інтелектом хорошим характером
та інстинктами
Я шукаю собак яких можна дресирувати
Спочатку треба допомогти їм пережити
травму вулиці
потім вони зможуть звикнути до людей
Якщо вдасться навчитися бути пошуковими
собаками
пошукове рятувальні собаки вкрай
необхідні після землетрусів які вже
неодноразово вражали Туреччину
лютневий катастрофічний землетрус забрав
життя щонайменше 50 тисяч людей на
південному сході країни
пошукові собаки допомогли врятувати
десятки людей
але їх було недостатньо більшість собак
привезли з-за кордону
Оксана Кер приходить до притулку для
тварин у пошуках кандидатів для свого
проекту
багато років він працював у
кінологічному підрозділі поліції по
боротьбі з наркотиками Він знає що
потрібно шукати у собаці
це дуже компанійський і не боїться людей
Спочатку я перевіряю чи він здоровий
потім дивлюся як він до неї з іншими
собаками зрештою з людьми
рятувальником у зоні землетрусу але без
собак тому що його собаки ще не були
навчені рятувальній справі тепер він
хоче якнайшвидше це виправити щоб бути
готовим до наступної катастрофи
добре навчені собаки не мають собі
рівних у пошуку жертв під завалами
вони завжди будуть кращими за технічні
засоби
спритність і нюх робить їх швидкими та
ефективними
Ось чому нам потрібно набагато більше
таких пошукових собак
еккер зробив заклик і багато власників
собак відгукнулися
сьогодні тренувальний день для собак
шукачів на його території за межами
Стамбула
бахаршин бахар прийшла зі своєю
дворняжкою Мейбл яка Колись жила на
вулиці
після землетрусу Я відчула себе такою
пригніченою І безпорадною що захотіла
зробити свій внесок щоб Наступного разу
ми були краще підготовленими Ось чому я
тут
потім собака і господар повинні показати
Чому вони навчилися ще раз понюхати і
вперед на пошуки зникли в лісі людини
Мейбл швидко бере Слід
і залишається біля людини як за
підручником
і Мейбл не єдина хто сьогодні доводить
що може бути пошуковою собакою
Ми хочемо більше поваги до собак на
вулицях
кожного отруєння чи вбита вулична собака
могла б врятувати людське життя
міжнародна суддя приїхала на
Випробування наступного дня
вона із ентузіазмом сприймає план ікера
навчити врятованих вуличних собак
рятувати людей
і собаки гідні кращого життя і не просто
кращого життя а такого що має сенс Це
чудово
бахар шенбахар і мейбл-і
швидко обнюхати річ зниклої людини і
тепер у собаки та господаря є 20 хвилин
цього разу вони не встигли але це не
провина собаки
я перенервувала і повела її не туди ми
вперше опинилися в такій ситуації
але ми все одно хочемо пройти
випробування в пошуку на завалах
Сподіваюся нам це вдасться
щоб перетворити вуличну собаку Мейбл на
рятівницю потрібні Терпіння і
наполегливі тренування але гектан гекер
твердо дотримується свого плану
підготувати достатню кількість пошукових
собак по всій Туреччині на випадок
надзвичайних ситуацій адже собаку
Туреччині більш ніж достатньо
[музика]
Хто сказав що неможливо навчити старого
пса новим трюкам А на сьогодні це все
дякуємо за перегляд і до зустрічі в
наступному випуску програми У фокусі
Європа українською мовою озвучено
центром медіа ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]